- hi there Steve Kaufman here I never
get my little blue snowball a little
closer I'm going to talk a bit about
tipster but before doing that I just
wanted to make up a video that's kind of
off the subject of language learning
except it deals with the subject of
words and in this politically correct
age words mean some things to some
people and something quite different to
other people recently there was an
article published in an Indo Canadian
magazine here in Vancouver called the
Surrey that's an area in the Greater
Vancouver area the surrey link not a
lion GQ but Li NK and the article is
written by a doctor Suraj Singh chairman
of the Washington State Network for
Human Rights and chairman of the Central
Washington Coalition for social justice
human rights and social justice
now this eminent defender of everything
is good in the world
writes an article where he basically
insinuates that the Americans are
somehow spreading cancer to Hugo Chavez
and a number of other Latin American
leaders doesn't quite explain how this
is being done but suggests that it's
very much possible because historically
the Europeans have done nasty things he
oh I should say that the title of his
article is racism capitalism and Zionism
are the worst cancers affecting the
world all right now but I thought the
most interesting comment in his article
was that the reason why sian ISM and
Israel is so strongly supported by the
u.s. is the answer can be found in
American history the American White's
are different from their European
ancestors he writes the bulk of American
White's were made from
don't worry too much about his English
the bulk of American whites were made
from the people who could not make it in
Europe they were underachievers the
other category were the criminals and
undesirable people who the whom who the
Europeans wanted to get rid of America
for all practical purposes was
considered a penal colony blah blah blah
the Jews therefore given this very
undesirable gene pool of the white
population doesn't specify these are
Scottish Irish Italian Ukrainian German
whatever but nor when they arrived you
know in the US but as there is all of
this weak gene pool he doesn't use the
word gene pool but he says because the
white immigrants were underachievers the
Jews were and still are able to
monopolize most of the academic and
intellectual demanding positions it is
very interesting to compare the
percentage of Jews amongst doctors
attorneys University professors and
plant scientists in America to any
European country and even to Canada the
truth is that the Jews are represented
in far greater numbers in these
professions than their population in
America yeah that's probably true
the Jews as well as people from East
Asia seem to overachieve an academic
pursuits education mama whatever the
reasons might be if mr. Singh chairman
of the Washington State University
Washington State Network for human
rights and defender of social justice
knew anything about history he would
know that the Jews who were also
overachieved in Europe were wiped out by
Hitler and that's why their numbers are
so small but the biggest thing of all is
that when he was challenged or this the
serene link paper was challenged for
presenting printing such garbage the
editor-in-chief or whatever he is that
certain mr. Dylan said well this is just
an opinion
and people write all kinds of nasty
stuff about us Sikhs and nobody ever
worries about it are you kidding me mr.
Dhillon if a newspaper in Vancouver
wrote an article saying that the Sikhs
came from some kind of an underachieving
gene pool and that's why they're all
berry pickers or words to that effect I
mean all hell would break loose whereas
here the leading and oldest and longest
established indoor Canadian newspaper
can print that all of a certain category
it happens to be Europeans or whites not
otherwise defined but let's pick another
group any group and say that they are
all under achievers and that's why they
do poorly relative to some other group
they can get away with it and then they
whine about how badly they're treated
all the time it is so annoying to hear
the constant whining from these groups
that have come to this country who are
better treated here than they were in
their own country where the employment
opportunities are far more open as
minorities to them then any minority
would have where they are if we talk
about the Sikhs try to be from another
province in India and move into into the
Punjab and see how well you looked after
I've heard that from our Sikh taxi
drivers there who tell me about the
blacks moving into the Punjab so fact
the matter is people are people people
have prejudices people don't like
certain other people all of that is fine
what really annoys me is this kind of
double standard whereby the chairman of
the Washington State Network for Human
Rights and chairman of the Central
Washington Coalition for social justice
can write in the most prestigious
indo-canadian newspaper and basically
categorically say that all the whites
were of some kind of an inferior stock
and that's why the Jews do so well I
mean come on let's get serious here I
hope someone takes them to a Human
Rights Tribunal they should take mr.
Singh
to the Canadian Human Rights Tribunal of
course they would never be heard never
be heard whereas if I can if a
mainstream magazine were to print
anything closely you know approaching
this kind of scurrilous screed they
would be for sure taken to the Human
Rights Tribunal anyway what can you do
I'll get back to language